If you want to see some evidence for the possibility
of a Stephen King cinematic universe, stick
around to the end of this video.
This shot was in teasers but I actually noticed
something new, you can see the crew and production
truck in the reflection here.
And speaking of reflections, remember how
I pointed out that there were no eyes in Pennywise's
reflection in the water, and said it may have
just been an unfinished visual effect that
would be added before the movie was released?
Well it looks like they have gone and added
that into this trailer.
Because as you can see, eyes should reflect
on water.
Here we see the lucky 7 all together in what
is presumably the barrens the place where
they hang out and build a fort to hide out
from Henry Bower's gang of bullies.
This has got to be the scene where they can
make the Promise.
If you're not familiar with the story, the
book begins with Mike Hanlon as an adult,
calling all the childhood friends to remind
them of the promise they made: that they would
return to Derry if IT were to ever come back.
Mike is holding his wrist in an awkward way.
It might be nothing, but I feel like it could
be that how wrist got hurt during the rock
fight with Henry Bowers gang.
This is a nice touch.
Before we saw a missing poster for Patrick
Hockstetter, but we weren't sure if that was
just an easter egg from the book, or if Patrick
was going to be an actual character.
Looks like he's going to be a part of it,
as the face is seen here along with what I
assume is Belch Huggins, Henry Bowers, which
is kind of confirmed because Henry has a knife
just like this in the book, and possibly Victor
Chris.
Even before this trailer dropped I had begun
to suspect that Patrick's story would be documented
in this new movie when I saw an article talking
about how IT would be taking advantage of
it's R-rating in ways that the mini series
just wasn't able to as a TV program.
I think if you're going to remake, reboot
or readapt something, you should have a good
reason for it, other than just money and making
a darker IT movie in order to to do justice
to the disturbing nature of the source material
is a green light in my book.
I'm not saying it's my book.
It's Stephen King's book.
I don't want to start that whole thing again.
Belch is wearing an Anthrax shirt, which is
interesting, because in the book, which is
set in the 50s rather than the 80s, one of
the few things that all of the kids seem to
agree on, Lucky 7 and Bowers Gang alike, is
their love for rock and roll; a love that
is not shared with seemingly any of the adults
in Derry.
That becomes kind of a motif, a symbolic representation,
of Pennywise's reign of terror in Derry.
Adults are in denial and kind of turn a blind
eye to the reality of the situation because
they are afraid of change, whether it be the
rise of rock & roll in the 50's, or the rise
of an evil being in their town.
So now with this being set in the 80s, maybe
metal serves that purpose now.
I certainly wouldn't mind seeing Richie jamming
out to Madhouse.
This Derry Newspaper is from 1908, one of
my personal favorite years in history, and
there is an article about the Iron Works Explosion.
So it would seem that despite moving up the
timeline involving our main characters, Derry's
past history has only shifted two years (it's
1906 in the book).
It's also a publication from July 4th, and
in this shot in the trailer, there seems to
be some kind of Independence Day Festival
going on in the background.
This is just speculation, but I'm thinking
something bad happens on the anniversary of
the Iron Works disaster.
The book Ben is reading is called A History
of Derry.
He also has a cassette player.
Look at the wallpaper behind Bill.
Circus animals.
Pennywise actually does have ancient ties
to a circus in the story, which is where he
got his name, Pennywise the Dancing Clown.
This whole basement scene is a pretty dark
in this shot, so let's turn up the lights.
In the corner there are some oars, and there's
also a life vest on the wall.
I wonder if these choices have anything to
do with the fact that Georgie dies while playing
with a paper boat, because he does appear
in this scene as an apparition.
Here's another dark scene.
Lumos Maxima!
Ok, this is creepy.
First thing I noticed is Pennywise sinking
into the well.
If Ringu didn't make wells creepy enough for
you it looks like the clown's got you covered.
There is also a hand on the side here, maybe
one of the kids pushing open a door.
Scattered on the floor are children's clothes
and toys.
This looks like an elephant, another circus
animal.
I know I said this adaptation would be darker,
but children's clothing?
This could be a lot more messed up than I
thought.
It's also shown in this other shot right here.
And there's also a nuise hanging from the
rafter.
This room full of various clowns has a few
things that I loved.
I'll turn up the lights again for you to make
it easier to see.
This little guy right here is a nice throwback
to the Tim Curry Pennywise design from the
1990 TV miniseries.
At first, I didn't notice this clown's head
turning to follow Eddie as he walks.
It's good to see something subtle like that
and know it's not just all jumpscares.
Bill wears a Tracker Bros t-shirt in this
shot.
It's a nice little easter egg referencing
the Tracker Bros shipping company, a family
owned trucking service in Derry from the book.
I'm really impressed by the level of detail
in this film.
Like the inclusion of Mr Keene, the pharmacist
who supplies Eddie with his inhalers.
Or the Glowing Yellow Eyes of the clown.
Some people theorized in my comment section
on the previous videos that this IT movie
could be tied in with The Dark Tower movie
that is coming out this year and also based
off of a Stephen King novel.
The movies aren't being made by the same studio
and I wasn't really a believer that there
could be a Stephen King cinematic universe
for that reason, as cool as it might sound,
but since then I have noticed some possible
clues pointing to one.
I definitely wouldn't say anything is confirmed,
and some of these are a little bit of a reach,
but I'm going to show you what I noticed,
and you can put your own findings in the comments.
Smith Coronna is a typewriter company.
The typewriter is a very important prop in
The Shining.
I already mentioned the Christine shirt in
my other video.
Then there's this newspaper headline that
says "No indictment yet in the Gillespie..."
and I wasn't able to read anything past that.
Gillespie is a character in Salem's Lot.
In fact, he's a cop.
By the way, did this shot kind of remind anyone
of Salem's Lot?
But the biggest thing for me is this Dark
Tower trailer that came out YESTERDAY.
In the title of the video are the words "connected
KINGdom".
It starts with an animation taking us through
the Overlook Hotel in The Shining.
Then it transitions to the Sewers of Derry
with the "The turtle can't help us" graffitied
on the wall.
If you don't know the significance of The
Turtle, an entity in both The Dark Tower and
IT, I suggest that you check out my last IT
video right here.
Then we're invited to the prom scene from
Carrie, Andy Defresne's prison cell in The
Shawshank Redemption, this is Christine, complete
with CQB 241 license plate, these are the
two main locations from The Stand and it all
leads back to The Dark Tower.
If you want to see a Stephen King cinematic
universe, leave a like on this video.
On Sunday at 5PM Eastern I'm going to be streaming
on the air for our first ever episode of The
Deadstream, it's a YouTube horror podcast
where we'll be talking about all kinds of
horror related topics.
All you have to do is subscribe to CZsWorld
and make sure you have your deathbell notifications
on and I hope to see you in The Deadstream.
Assuming we both survive.